hello walk into welcome to this video
playing a sip team again lost a tricky
game against him earlier okay
unconventional line in the Sicilian God
and we start with the with the weird
stuff early okay what to do a g6
probably check
yeah it doesn't look great but I didn't
want to spend a million years in this in
this opening position and then do it on
time against the sky any proof to be
tricky anyway and that in that earlier
game okay I'm happy that he didn't take
my bishop h4 h5 film here we go oh yeah
it's developed stuff yeah absolutely not
paying any attention to what I'm doing
probably deservedly so um an IT force my
idea maybe this is not working at all I
don't care no see 65 but today it's not
that convincing probably should be
scrapped on itself what an idea you can
even just castle now
yeah I don't know I just I just played
his position poppy stop what I know
yeah I guess I felt kind of provoked by
that by that somewhat strange opening
but I know it sounds a bit weird maybe
but I'm not even sure this is this is
such a super clear position I mean
certainly from a purely objective point
of view yes but it feels like I still
have some slight initiative him so
can take them I can also bring that rook
over so the antiquing doesn't help on g3
let's do this this looks completely
wacky the ideas rook takes you three
actually of it it does have an idea
maybe you can just play Bishop you for
something I don't know my adduct you
three as something is serious hmm I
would just add to fend against my idea I
don't think it does actually 24 is
interesting i grouped you to its mate
okay I was thinking queena age to could
lead to a mate but it doesn't yeah now
Queen after a pre an age to mate it's
kind of serious like resigns yeah I
don't know rookie 3 is said winning it
does winner funny it's really a when
look III black wins so I spotted a
tactic for once yeah it's nicer he
cannot defend against the troop g3 is
pretty pretty awful yeah okay I mean my
piece sacrifice was just I know kind of
i was a bit frustrated by his opening
play like it what would they had a cage
fine whatever it's it's just okay right
it's not that that is playing badly with
I felt can you provoked and this is just
just not working at all not at all but
somehow the way it was played I had to
head something yeah I mean this all
helps a little bit yeah it takes Bishop
cheeks but wyd win so I should win again
22 Bishop tv8 is already doing me a
little something but it's it's all still
okay that's funny he has to go piggy one
it's really remarkable after this rook
e8 the the engine gives as this as equal
because them because rookie 3 is such a
big threat it wants to play this rookie
3 and then save the day and with Knight
to f3 and now I can make a draw no I can
actually win now it finds a win with
Bishop g2 okay check and Ruby fire ha
yeah black the techs decison so Wow is
that what does that mean is said already
lost then not everyone is now given by
the engine as a new try but this is not
it is something where the computer will
give you the correct result of course
but it might take a while until it gets
deep enough to be precise about what's
happening I have stopped with running
now and it's getting deeper in this
calculation and per second the
evaluation is going down now black is on
minus 1.2 already with the move rupee 6
just rookie 6 m-f to e8 building up our
Plex remaining pieces are remarkably
active this is the computers main line
and duvall good this is the enders
midline supposedly the best that why i
can get now it's no fun and this is what
he did I know rookie 3 is winning here
amazing yeah so we can shake this this
is already a force checkmate and this is
the chatter checkmate the line if it
goes here he takes now a threatening
taking on f2 and Bishop g3 or this one
check two oops no again I made yeah okay
played this and now group 2 3 there is
no defense it's remarkable and 24 I'm
chechik meeting with this check check
check mate I was actually checking that
might win as well with China he's
escaping yeah and he cannot avoid the
meter that's a very nice end of the game
I mean that P sacrifice was just bonkers
but it had led to a very nice finish of
the game thanks for watching